سعود مش سهل
اول اشي اهلا وسهلا
[تصفيق]
رح ابلش معكم بقصه صغيره بس هاي قصه قبل
النوم تشبهها شوي بس
راح احكي لكم قصتي باختصار وشو الهدف فيها
لانكم انتم طلاب بالجامعه
بيوم من الايام داخله على الجامعه متحمسه
سنه اولى بالجامعه مثل كل حدا داخل
الجامعه بالعاده اول ما ندخل الجامعه
بتكون متحمسين نعيش حياه الجامعه
للماكسيموم كنت تركيزنا بالدراسه مش هالقد
بس انا ما تخيلت انه كان حيصير معي امتحان
من نوع مختلف كانت اعراض شوي مختلفه
هالامتحان فاجاني بانه يكون بصحتي
هالامتحان فاجاني بمعلومات انا ما عندي اي
تجربه فيها وما عندي معلومه كيف ابلش
ادرسها وافهمها
كانت تجربتي بمرض السرطان
سرطان كل ما بتخض وبتخوف وكلياتنا بس
نسمعها منقول هشهش هذاك المرض الله يجيرنا
منه
طبعا رحت على عمه جوجل كلياتنا منروح على
عمو جوجل
طبعا
بالعاده لما نعمل سيرش على جوجل اغلب
المعلومات اللي بتطلع لنا للاسف بهذاك
الوقت كانت شوي نوعا ما مخيفه محبطه
مغلوطه
شو كان حلي قلت خلاص بدنا نسكر الجوجل انا
لازم اعيش هاي التجربه
شو المفروض اعمل
جهزت حالي كيف جهزت حالي بتعرفوا مثل اي
صبيه بتكون بهذا العمر مبسوطه بانوثتها
بشكلها
وشعر البنت بعز عليها لانه هو
قوتها وانهتها بتمثل فيه
قررت اعمل احتفاليه كانت احتفاليه مع
صاحباتي
احلقولي شعري
ليش لاني كنت رافضه اني اشوف شعري عم بقع
على المخده بسبب العلاج
فعليا حلقت شعري ورحت جاهزه رحت جاهزه
للامتحان
صدقوني
ربنا لما ببتلينا باي اشي بحياتنا شو ما
كانت المشكله اللي عندكم اياها في ابتلاء
وبينزل عليكم بنفس الوقت سكينه ما بتعرفوا
من وين ما بتعرفوا شو الشعور قديه مريح
لدرجه انه الدكاتره كانوا مفكريني اني انا
متعرضه لصدمه اني لسه مش فاهمه
كان عندي قناعه انه هالتجربه اللي انا هلا
فيها هي لسبب انا هلا مش فاهمه شو هو لكن
متاكده انه هو سبب كثير كبير
وتغيير مصيري بحياتي
مريت بتجربه العلاج طبعا تجربه العلاج
الطويله
وخلصت اول سنه طبعا السعاده بالتخرج انه
لما يجي الدكتور يقول لي لما خلصت العلاج
كانت احلى لحظه بالحياه الانتصار
طيب خلصنا علاج طب سنه كامله انا عايشه
بين المستشفى والجامعه
صار في عندي فراغ بالوقت الوقت اللي كنت
اروح فيه على المستشفى شو بدي اعمل طيب
اصحابي تغيروا انا الناس اللي صرت
مصاحبتهم مرضى بالمستشفى حتى مواضيع حياتي
اختلفت رجعت مثل البيبي البيبي كيف بده
يرجع يحاول يمشي نفس الشيء
السنه اللي كنت بدي ارجع فيها اتعود كيف
الحياه الاجتماعيه والطبيعيه بدون المرض
ما كان سهله لانه في عامل نفسي باثر فينا
كثير كبير لانه مرات الناس بتقول طاب او
عدى المرحله ليش بعدك متاثر
وقتها بلشت انتبه انه في موضوع كثير مهم
غير الصحه الجسديه الصحه النفسيه
والروحانيه
مرقت هالسنه طبعا بحب اقول لكم غيرتها
ثلاث تخصصات ابدعت التخصص اللي ما اضبط
فيه انقل على الثاني
[ضحك]
الاخيره يعني بدي بالثالثه بعد تخصصات
اللي غيرتهم خلاص انا يعني نفسيتي انه انا
الخريجه ضايل لي مش ضايل كتير
بتلفون من دكتوري لانه انا كان عندي
فحوصات دوريه لما
رجع لك المرض
متخيلين قديش شعور صعب
متخيلين كيف كلياتنا وانا متاكده كل واحد
فيكم لما يوقع باي مشكله بحياته اول شيء
بحكي ليش انا هذا اول سؤال بخطر على بالنا
ليش انا بعدين نمرق بمراحل
الانكار للغضب نوصل للقبول
وهون راح اجي احكيلكم عن كل مسحريه
كلمه سحريه انا عايشه عليها بكل حياتي
اليقين
هالكلمه هاي لو بنعرف شو معناها
فعليا منحسها ومنعيشها
الحياه بتكون كتير سهله
بحب افاجئكم انا طبعا الحمد لله هي حياتي
من الولاده كانت فيها
انا حتى بنت مولوده ست اشهر مش حتى مكمله
تسع اشهر
فلما اجاني الخبر انه انصبت بالكانسر
للمره الثانيه
لما يوصل النقاش بيني وبين الدكتور انه شو
انواع العلاج المتبقيه الي يعني الخيارات
عم بتقل
طيب لبنت عمرها 20 21 سنه كان المفروض
يكون اكبر اهتمامها خايفه من الامتحان
الفاينال
اجي انسى ايش الخيارات اللي قدامي
اشي كثير صعب
قلت اني اخذ نوع كيماوي هو نوعا ما صعب
كثير وتركت اوبشن زراعه النخاع لا سمح
الله اذا صابني الكانسر للمره الثالثه
بعد هيك بلش برضه برحله العلاج
بس بهاي المره الامتحان صار اصعب والاعراض
اصعب
وصفى قدرتي اني انا اقدر ادرس واكمل جامعه
طبعا في سنه كامله اسقطها
شو الهدف من هاي الجزئيه اللي كنت عم بقول
لكم اياها
بعز علي بس اسمع ايه طالب جامعه يقول لي
صعب مش قادر
صدقوني
للاسف مرات بتصير تصرفات فرديه هي بتصير
لنكتشف قوتنا
بلحظه ضعف في دكتوره لالي بالجامعه
صار عندي غيابات كتير للاسف كتصرف فردي
كان ردها علي الله يشفيك اللي مثلك يقعد
بالبيت
بسبب هذه الجمله بشكر دكتورتي على هاي
الجمله لانها كانت مصدر قوه ليلي
سبب هاي الجمله قررت انه انا مش اقل من اي
انسان
بدون
اسباب ثانيه سواء مريض او عندي اي سبب
يمنعني من الدراسه انا راح اتخرجوا اجيب
شهاده الجامعه
فعليا قدمت امتحانات بغرفه عزل
وتخرجت تخريج خاص من الدكتور خالد الكركي
احمد خرجت زي الباقيين
لكن فعليا
تعلمت انه اكبر هم بهذاك العمر او هلا
ممكن اكتر اشي تكونوا خايفين منه كيف بدي
اتخرج من الجامعه
بس السر الحقيقي اللي بدي اقول لكم اياه
في شغله كتير مهمه كان عم بحكي عنها دكتور
اسامه الستريس
تعلمت من هذا الحكي انه احنا بطبيعتنا
دائما علقانين علقانين بين الماضي
ومشاكله والعقد اللي انحطت فينا
وخايفين من المستقبل اللي احنا لسه مو
ضامنينه ومش عارفين اذا راح نعيشه مين منا
بعيش هلا مين منا بعيش الثانيه مين منا
هلا بلحظه ما بيكون مركز انه هلا بدي اضحك
خليني انبسط وهلا قاعد مع عيلتي خليني
انبسط معهم
من هذا الحكي هذا طبعا تاثير اللي بعتبره
الجانب السلبي من السوشيال ميديا
خلتنا شوي نبعد عن الجانب الانساني
والروحاني اللي عنا اياه
خلتنا ناس شوي ما نكون اقرب لانسانيتنا
ومخاوتنا صارت اكبر
صرنا نخاف نخاف نحكي انه احنا مش عنا حياه
بيرفكت لازم اكون لابسه اللبس الفلانيه
ولازم احكي بالطريقه الفلانيه واتغذى
بالمكان الفلاني
ليش
ومشان مين وبدي ارضي مين
كل حدا قاعد هون فكروا بنقطه كتير مهمه
هاي حياتكم انتم مش حياه اي شخص تاني
الوقت كتير مهم
الوقت كيف مهم
السر قديت عيشه السر كيف تعيشوا حياتكم
السر هل الحياه اللي انتو عشتوها رضيانين
عنها
هل فعليا انه انتو حققتوا احلامكم
وامانيكم
بحب اعترف لكم اعتراف
وقفتي قدامكم كانت حلم
وهي صارت حقيقه
اللي قدامكم نفس البنت اللي كانت واقفه
قدام مرايه وصلعه
وتبكي وما كانت شايفه الها مستقبل ولا
حياه نفسها البنت اللي كانوا يقولوا لها
مريضه كانسر طب يعني وخلصت جامعه طب رح
تتجوز
اتجوزت على 35 ما تسالوني قديه عمري هلا
ما في اشي مستحيل كلمه مستحيل امحوها من
القاموس انتم بس اللي عليكم اشي واحد
تامنوا بحالكم وقوتكم وطاقتكم كل انسان
قاعد هون وكل شخص انت شخص ملهم
احنا من خلقنا على هاي الحياه عبتا
يعني وربنا كريم كريم كريم
معقول ربنا اللي سخر لنا الكون هذا كله كل
هذا الكون ملككم ليه بنصغر احلامنا ليه
بنخليها مستحيله احنا اللي عم نخليها
مستحيله وصعبه
بامكانكم ايش ما كنتوا بدكم تحلموا تحققوا
منها المرضى بدي احكيلكم عن اشي كمان ممكن
نفكر انه اكبر مخاوفنا بموضوع معين
لما اجى الدكتور وبرضو قال لي لمى خلصنا
قال لي لكن مناعتك نازله لازم تكوني بغرفه
العزل
طبعا بطبيعتي كنت مزيحه زياده عن اللزوم
وهاي بتعرفوا اللي مش دايما لازم تمزحوا
في مواقف ما بزبطش تمزحوا فيها
انا كنت بغرفه العزل وكان عندي الممرضين
لكن بفجاه واقل من ثواني راح النفس ولما
فتحت عيوني لقيت حالي بغرفه عزل
بالاي سي يو
دكتوره فوق راسي
مشبكه بسلاك على وجهي ماسك بقفوله ودكتوره
بتقول لي انت هلا على الاجهزه قدامك 48
ساعه بس
48 ساعه ضمن البروتوكول احنا مضطرين عشان
نقدر نرجع
الرئه للمره الثانيه لانه انت اجاكي فيروس
وتوقفوا الرئتين
طبعا كطبيبه برجع بقول لكم برضو في مواقف
بتاثر بحياتنا بتكون بدل ما تضعفنا
بتقوينا
طلبت مني الدكتوره قالت لي شو هي اخر
احلامك
طبعا ما بقدر بحب فريندز كان جاي عبالي
اضحك قلت لها بدي احضر فريندز وبدي اسمع
سوره البقره بصوت السديس وبدي دفتر رسم
والوان
والله قعدت ارسم
وقدامي ساعه
بس ساعه ساعه وعم بطلع عالوقت انعشوني
مرتين وانا صاحيه كنت اشوف الغرفه وهي
بتضوي كل الالوان
وتذكرت
تذكرت امي باول مره اهدتني كتاب قوه عقلك
الباطن كنت عامله زي الغريق لما نعلق بقشه
تذكرت هذا الكتاب وقررت اني اامن بقوه
الداخليه
وامن بربي
لانه ربي هو الاساس الله اللي ابتلاني
بهذا المرض هو وحده القادر على الشفاء بس
ربنا قلنا كمان امنوا بقوتكم
وامنه بقدرتكم وطاقتكم ما في شيء مستحيل
غمضت عيوني وتخيلت وضلتني اتخيل كانه
الرئه بشتغل
وكانت عندي جمله اصرار لانه قالوا لي اذا
طلعت من الاي سي يو على الاغلب راح تكوني
مشلوله
وهيني قدامكم واقفه على اجري
صدقوني وقفتي هون قدامكم
تعني لي كتير لسبب
من هذاك الوقت اذا عندي دور ورساله
بالحياه
كل ما اشوف حدا مكتئب بقول نفسي اقيم عنه
الغيمه السوداء هاي ويطلع قديه في نعم
حلوه اذا في نصيحه ممكن احكيلكم اياها
تعلموا صبحوا ليل
تحمدوا الله على النعم اكتبوهم خلوها زي
واجب كيف عم تدرسوا بالصبح وبالليل وكل ما
تضيق الدنيا فيكم
اتذكروا انه هذا الكون وهاي الحياه كلها
ملككم بس شغلتين بدنا نركز عليهم قلبنا
طول ما هو نقي وعنا رضا رضا داخلي ويقين
وعقلنا نستخدمه بنعمل المعجزات فخوره اني
بينكم بين اهلي وناسي
وشكرا كتير لالكم انه سمحتولي اكون معاكم
اليوم شكرا
[تصفيق]